welcome back to Facebook and sensor I've
taken a bold stand against the
unsporting treachery at Lords on Sunday
by the Australian cricket team the
Australian present turn has taken an
equally bold stand well against me take
a look at this morning's Daily Telegraph
in Sydney has dressed me Ben Stokes the
Jeffrey boycott and Richie sunac as
giant babies with the headline a wobbly
lower lip Sookie Palms keeps spitting
the dummy well I'm joined by Chief
Cricket writer of the Australian Peter
Layla well Peter uh great to have you on
the show uh you were on your podcast
yesterday saying I've been ignoring all
messages from radio and television I'm
only disappointed I didn't have enough
time to go on Piers Morgan so I'd have
loved to have gone on that it would have
been very entertaining well now's your
chance to see how entertaining is going
to be Peter uh right let me start with
with this I want to show you again what
happened just to remind everybody this
is what went down here we go
so another short ball
for those who don't play a lot of
cricket what's happening Johnny bairstow
doesn't even try and hit the ball he
just Ducks the ball goes over his head
he then scrapes his boot inside the
crease you see him here from this angle
so when he scrapes his boot he's
denoting the fact it's the end of the
over six balls have been bold They're
Gonna Change ends scrapes his boot
everyone in world cricket history knows
that denotes but the batsman is marking
his crease and then he goes up to walk
to his captain and at that point I don't
blame the Wicket keeper Mr Kerry for
what he did he instinctively threw the
ball fine the person I blame Peter is
your captain Pat Cummings and here's why
three years ago the Australian cricket
team were in total Global disgrace over
sandpaper gay I think you were pretty
sensorious yourself about it and here we
have a chance three years on the
Australian team to show that they really
have changed their spots and actually do
believe in the spirit of the game
sometimes overriding the basic laws what
happened why didn't Cummings withdraw
that appeal and bring Johnny bastard
back you don't in your guts feel
comfortable about what you saw dude
a hundred percent comfortable anybody
who plays qriket peers knows that the
over is not over until the Umpire calls
it over
um let's there's a lot of people making
a lot of noise about this and sounding
like you but uh there's Michael Vaughn
Michael Atherton NASA stain uh Andrew
Strauss four people who have won a few
things in common they capped in England
and they agree with Australia's position
on this it was out he was Dopey it was
dozy it was stupid well hang on on all
of those I agree with you he was out he
was Dopey he was dozy and he was from a
cricketing perspective stupid I don't
disagree with any of that I think what
my wider point though is that given
everything that the Aussies have been
through with the cricket team in the
last few years in terms of the spirit of
the game yeah right and downright
cheating frankly with a sandpaper gay I
don't accuse the team of cheating this
time I didn't like the scenes in the
laws Pavilion it's not cheating but I
would I would equate it to what happened
with Trevor Chapel in think it was 91
wasn't it when he when he was captained
by his brother Greg and they were
playing a one-day International against
New Zealand and Trevor Chapel was
directed by his brother to bowl the last
ball of the match where New Zealand
wanted six to win to bowl it underarm
and he bowled under her and he created
such a fury that even the older Chapel
brother Ian Chapel condemned it on the
commentary box Richie Banner called it
one of the worst things he'd ever seen
both Prime Ministers of both countries
condemned it uh in fact Muldoon the New
Zealand prime minister said that he
thought it was appropriate Australia
were wearing yellow shirts and so on and
they changed the law as a result isn't
this the same well you've got something
which is typically within the rules it's
in the laws of the game but everybody
felt uncomfortable and you cite all the
captains of England who defend it fine
the public to a man and woman I've
spoken to all think this was wrong
Trevor Chapel's Act was an extraordinary
act and I think we all condemn it this
is sorry just on that point Johnny
Johnny
on that one point Murphy's tweeted me
tweeted today that he thinks it was
completely Justified what Trevor Chapel
did so not everyone thinks it was wrong
you're all right that's moved that's our
move yes there's a joker in every pack
um Johnny bestow attempts the same
dismissals in the same very same test
match no he attempted it in the previous
team the same thing the batsman was out
of their crease he attempted to throw
down the batsman is taking guard outside
the crease and therefore he plays and
misses the Wicket keeper has a
legitimate chance to stump him if he
took guard outside the crease bear so
clearly here scrapes his boot inside the
crease he clearly scrapes his boot
everybody knows what he's doing there he
is saying I'm marking the end of the
over and the both umpires have moved to
move away right come on this is not the
spirit of cricket and you're a very
experience writer and I just don't
believe you if it was the other way
around I don't think you'd be saying the
same thing
happens every weekend in club Cricket in
Australia I don't know what you do here
it's not up to Johnny Bear so to decide
where or when it and over ends it's up
to Johnny basto to respect the laws of
cricket which were written by the
English and to stay in his crease until
it's safe to get out of that crease if
he wants to get out of that crease while
the ball is live He's fair game I'm
sorry
I think your country's kind of lost its
mind over this and I reckon it's a bit
of a smoke screen to be honest you two
nil down in the ashes you've all been
sort of doing handstands about this this
great new brand of cricket you could
play baseball and good on you it's
fantastic it's exciting Cricket but
it's face planted in the acids you two
nil down and you're carrying on about a
flies back on a Pulpit well we should
have won an edge but I don't understand
what's going on
we should have won an ashbastian and if
Ben Stokes catches lion when he's on two
it's all over and secondly in this last
test match if you hadn't basically
divvied out or Alberto we'd have won
that match too so we probably would have
been tuned a lot
you know um you talk about the spirit of
Cricket the spirit of cricket talks
about accepting the authority of the
umpires of creating a positive
atmosphere in the way you play I mean I
find I I think that English cricketers
owes Australia an apology
is Mother's yes but you just said
yourself
that absolute hooliganism of laws well
that I agree with absolutely okay no no
from your members and from the public
and it's being and it's been experiment
by your team attempting to cover up let
me respond the fact that it lost it's
two nil down let me respond I agree that
the behavior of the members chanting
cheat cheat was wrong they shouldn't
have done it and that is ungracious but
the idea you as an Australian are going
to lecture us on the way crowds treat
the opponents I was at the ashes in
2013-14 where obeying mob with literally
bang for blood and in fact they were
being at one stage from my blood against
Brett Lee so I won't say any elections
from you law on how crowds behave
our crowds behave poorly too but we're
not claiming to set the standards and
I'll tell you what our crowds haven't
been jostling jostling players
did you know Steven Smith
I want to thank you for coming on
because very few others would come on I
appreciate it the ashes is now
incendiary headingley will be an avatar
a new lot are going down 3-2 thank you
for coming on Peter Layla not a chance
start shopping